wat die hier mandlijn nog steeds overslaat is en betoog
is dat wij nog heel veel dissenia
in de gebouwde omgeving
echt wel aardrijkskunde gebruiken
en iets van beetje ook
en wat die ook overslaat is
dat echt Anders dan 5 jaar geleden
vooraafgaan aan het klimaterkoord toegesloot
dus toen werd echt gedacht
ongeveer 1/3 van de van de huis in Nederland gaat gaat
aangewezen zijn op 1 warme net
ik denk dat het hoog uit de helft wordt
dus de oplossing
voor collectieverwarmte
die zal veel kleinschaliger zijn en veel
kleiner in ontvang
dan 1 aantal jaren geleden werd geridoneerd
dat inzicht is echt bij iedereen
het is gewoon 1 Klein schalige oplossing
maar alleen het netverzwaren
ja dat gaan we niet daarmee gaan we niet redden
en deze wet
is ook bedoeld om mensen van het Gras af te dwingen
dus uh en en
ja of het nou om om 1 miljoen huizen gaat of 2 of 3
je zal maar zo in zo'n huis wonen en
uh 1 monopoly 1 monopolist
jouw warmte moeten laten voor zien